pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand les chants des gros spirituel ce
mélange rythmes du maloya c'est toujours
pour chanter la liberté et dénoncer
l'oppression
après trois mois de travail en commun
christine salem et deborah une chanteuse
américaine de gospel partage avec le
public réunionnais leurs compositions
musicales à la chapelle pointue de vie
des histoires
au début les particuliers apprennent
bien
ces chansons là on a un rapport avec la
liberté quelque part la chapelle pointue
et le musée de vilaine ont été mises à
disposition de ces deux chanteuses dans
le cadre d'une résidence artistique
accompagné par le département de la
réunion un travail de composition
musicale sur les chants d'esclaves
intitulé quand les champs de canne
rencontre les champs de coton au conseil
général à faire un appel à projets de
création résidence patrimoine qui nous
l'a proposé ce projet là avec deborah de
travailler seul et sur les chants
d'esclaves le temps n'en prennent aussi
beaucoup de choses sur l'histoire de
l'esclavagé en général a réuni pendant
deux heures le public a découvert et
écouter le travail de ces deux
musiciennes qui ont pu composer ses
champs grâce au dispositif de la
résidence d'artistes
[Musique]